[Music]
yeah so graham is he's 31 years old
close to my age and he is a he's a big
deal on youtube he's got 3.74 million
subscribers and his channel is all about
finances mainly he focuses on real
estate investing oh boy and other types
of investing and so he made a lot of
money at a young age in his 20s became a
millionaire all right through this
process and he he makes a whole lot of
money now about six million a year
through all of his youtube ad revenue
sponsorships affiliates that's
extraordinary and so he's a good kid we
disagree on a lot of things uh our views
on debt very different our views on
investing very different but i saw this
clip and i thought you know what he
actually has something interesting to
say here that i think we can all agree
with all right so let's roll it
i would say the smartest financial
decision was uh
probably investing in real estate and
and living now i would say is living
below my means living so extreme for so
long i would say it really was not until
about
a year it was a year ago when i started
like
spending money
a year ago and even then it's it's not
been like frivolous stuff but
a year ago i wasn't even in here i was
in an 800 square foot duplex it was a
one bedroom one bathroom
um
worked from the garage and i had kept
that up i mean i was i was doing even
over a million dollars a year still
living in that same 800 square foot
duplex in mid city like this this i
don't want to say it was like a bad area
but like when you think of the income
you you don't think of like mid-city l.a
um
and uh yeah and i just didn't spend any
money and that was the best financial
decision ever this this house was the
first time i had ever done something for
myself was this
wow look at that this is a youngster
uh
social media star living below his means
yeah and he started with
my best financial decision i ever made
real estate investing he goes no no yeah
i like that he backed it off you know
what it was living on less than i made
and that is a principle that we can
definitely agree on this man was
bringing in a million dollars a year
living in the 700 square foot place he
could have got a nicer place but he said
you know what i'm gonna sacrifice for a
period of time
so that i can achieve my bigger goals i
don't need to get all flashy now and
have this lifestyle creep now that i
make good money i'm gonna go spend it
and be real flashy and so i really
respect his hard work his sacrifice he's
a hardworking dude
even today making those youtube videos
is not easy and he puts in the work and
i think aside from you know
us disagreeing about leveraging debt and
doing the real estate his way i think we
can agree that we need more young people
who are willing to sacrifice who are
willing to not compare themselves to
other people that's right who are
willing to do the hard work to get to
where they want to go so what's at the
base of that george there's a real
takeaway too from this
because of a successful young guy like
this what he's saying is without saying
it
he was focused on the future not the
present if i'm present focused hey i'm
making a million dollars i'm going to
start living it up i'm going to spend it
if i'm future focused i don't even
realize i don't even think much about my
800 square foot duplex he didn't say
that yeah but that is synonymous among
all successful people whether we agree
with the way they handle their money or
not successful people have a focus on
the future they make decisions that are
not based on the now
they make decisions that are based on
the future so the now becomes
prioritized it's like i will make great
decisions in the now if i am focused on
how they affect my future that's another
big takeaway that i don't want young
people to miss one of our debt-free
screamers recently said you gotta have a
vision beyond friday
man
i'd like to steal that yes i hope no one
was listening to that but i think that's
at the heart of that a lot of these
young people they follow graham they
follow his youtube channel they
subscribe because they want to be like
graham they want to be wealthy at a
young age they have options and freedom
and meaning and all this kind of stuff
they don't want to work till they're 65
in a job they hate you rally against
this stuff all the time ken but i think
at the heart of this the young people
need to understand that you can get rich
quick but you can lose it even quicker
oh boy and the way you keep your wealth
once you build it is by living on less
than you make it's truth it's truth
just look up some of these high profile
athletes that have blown hundreds of
millions of dollars he's one of my
favorite fighters of all time but if you
want to look out for the caution evander
holyfield my goodness gracious uh we're
talking about unbelievable earnings and
you can spend it so fast
so on the way up learn how to live on
the lesson you make really good stuff
george thanks for the clip yeah we had
to be a little bit positive see who says
you can't learn from the talk
well that's to be tbd
but there really is some great content
on the same people that are rallying
against tick tock are also watching
instagram reels and sending them to me
oh they're watching videos on facebook
let's be honest it's all the same
videos everybody's got their social
media opinions